en el este de sudán del sur aquí el sol
ardiente y la constante inseguridad
impiden cualquier actividad agrícola una
aldea como muchas otras en sudan del sur
que es a la vez víctima y protagonista
de los conflictos intercomunitarios hace
unas semanas como duch fue atacada por
varios grupos étnicos vecinos ayuda
alimentaria vehículos los atacantes
quemaron todo a su paso por segunda vez
en dos años jacov ha perdido su pequeña
tienda en el mercado
por aquí había puestos pero llegaron los
atacan tomaron todo
perteneciente a la etnia murle jeyko que
explica que no siempre hubo tanta
violencia
antes de la independencia los burles no
éramos agredidos había una pasco
existente entre las comunidades ahora
los ataques son frecuentes y muchas
personas mueren las mujeres y los niños
son secuestrados
como en gurú la violencia étnica está
desestabilizando todo el país en un
intento por aliviar las tensiones
tribales y resolver sus conflictos
algunas ong reúnen a los enemigos de
ayer 59 y murle
este año ya hemos hecho las paces entre
nuestras comunidades
hemos establecido normas y hemos puesto
fin al conflicto pero a pesar de ello
los mir le vinieron a atacar a matarnos
12 veces igual estamos cansados de ser
víctimas burle peleado víctimas naves
anuales cuando llegamos aquí vimos que
los noble no tiene unos mentales ni
escuelas de la ual y tampoco tenemos en
casa entender mejor los ataques entre
comunidades suelen tener como objetivo
el robo de ganado son responsables del
78 por ciento de las víctimas de la
violencia en el país según la onu
antes de la partición con jartúm los
conflictos interétnicos no eran tan
numerosos como ahora en aquella época
nos hablamos en el enemigo común jartúm
pero ahora desde que sudan del sur
obtuvo la independencia las comunidades
se están muriendo de hambre y se ha
convertido en una pugna de unas contra
otras que aún en una independencia de
arrancada por yubá sudán en 2011 tras
décadas de lucha y un importante apoyo
de eeuu pero muy pronto aparecen
divisiones en la nueva nación
desde lo complete los motivos del
conflicto están relacionados con una
lucha de poder
y cierto grupo de nuestros oficiales del
ejército popular de liberación de sudán
dirigidos por riesgo marchar
el 1er pensaron que estaban tomándose el
poder por la fuerza y eso condujo a la
guerra civil y perú o una acusación de
golpe de estado que siempre fue negada
por riek machar esta lucha de poder
entre el vicepresidente y el presidente
salva kiir condujo a una guerra civil de
seis años a la que se puso fin
oficialmente con los acuerdos de paz de
2018 pero fuera de yubá la inseguridad
persiste la situación es más dramática
en la región administrativa de pibor en
el este del país debido a la violencia y
a la falta de cosecha
la gente corre el riesgo de morir de
hambre los alimentos se transportan en
helicóptero oa veces se lanzan desde
unos aviones cuando la ayuda alimentaria
llega los lugareños se encuentran algo
de esperanza aquí algunos como esta
joven madre llevan días sin comer debido
a un reciente ataque y me alegro mucho
de que esta comida llegue esto me
ayudará mucho a alimentar a mi hijo en
estas zonas remotas el suministro de
ayuda humanitaria es un reto logístico
entre en la época de lluvias las pocas
carreteras que hay en la mayoría de
ellas de tierra se vuelven
intransitables transición que el
programa mundial de alimentos tiene que
volar para
los alimentos y la asistencia que se
necesitan para mantener a los vienen y a
descubrir más del 60 por ciento de los
cánceres sufren inseguridad alimentaria
extrema esto significa que cada vez
pasan más hambre son capaces de proveer
sean alimentos a sí mismos ya sus seres
queridos aquí muchos niños sufren de
desnutrición severa chacha perdió a su
marido y su ganado durante el ataque de
una aldea cercana el año pasado
sobrevive recogiendo frutos silvestres
desde entonces no tengo comida para
darle a mi hijo para que al menos esté
sano antes de la independencia del país
mi vida era mejor no había ataques del
ganado no era saqueadores y mi marido
seguía acá
aquí la comunidad sobrevive casi
únicamente con la ayuda internacional
en esta comida un respiro pero sigo
teniendo a mi lado
en cualquier momento se pueden reanudar
los ataques me temo que voy a tener que
huir y tirar esa comedia y si por algún
milagro regreso con vida no tendré nada
que comer banales años después de la
independencia más de siete millones de
sudaneses del sur sufren una grave
inseguridad alimentaria el 33 por ciento
de los niños están desnutridos según el
programa mundial de alimentos